[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
what's going on
everyone man this is the attic show
we're back here it's the first year uh
first week we've been back of 2021
22 22 we had to we had to get that right
22. uh it's been a little bit man how
you doing hustle how are you doing
man photo finish yet again i kind of
just walked through the door myself
go ahead time to you know freshen up
brush my teeth and you know take care of
some other things but i'm good i'm good
um i feel like my battery has been
recharged i ain't been here in like a
month what's been going on man it's been
that long it's really been that long um
you watching youtube right now
no i had to turn the tv off
okay
yeah i forgot it was completely on man i
was sitting there and i was like i hear
something in the background but what is
it
oh sir i'm off in this
my camera's fine but i mean like the box
is off yeah i don't know what happened
there hold up let me fix it
maybe when you joined in it made
everyone bigger for some reason
very well could've uh only on xbox i see
you in there what's going on sir uh
splendiferous
uh outbreak podcast hello
it just take a couple seconds to get uh
what what's going on man the chat yeah i
i sense the energy in the chat right now
man it feel it feels like
when it comes to
i don't know why like okay first it
wasn't too bad but i don't know what i
don't know what it was hustle
i i i was in the
the hurry just to get like back to
regular programming if that makes sense
to you because it's just like after
about like the 23rd 24th i'm like i just
i just want to go ahead and just go back
to regular programming i don't know you
do something so long you get so used to
it it kind of like feels weird when you
take too too much of a break from it you
got to look
you got a little restless you got a
little restless me myself i've kind of
enjoyed my break and i got some special
things coming starting next month
on february 15th i will be back on
twitch um i kind of had alluded to some
stuff but
i got i got a whole little little
rollout holo playing going i feel good
so good and i enjoy i enjoyed the time
off man just you know i just want my
people with my with my family you know
play some games here and there i didn't
have a chance to catch up with you
unfortunately but
yeah i mean it'll all work itself out
but i feel good i feel like well rested
is the word like i was like anticipating
the doing this because like you hit me
up he's like hustle we back on today i'm
like all right
i'm thinking we're going to take the
extended break like you know like a
weapon wheel or you know all these other
podcasts running around but well i was
so i'll please sunday what's up
i hit you up like i think it was this
morning or last night
and uh i was just if you wasn't good i
was just gonna come anyway you know
because
i'm ready to get back to them and i
equal a lot like i was so happy when iop
started sunday
like because
because uh you know after you you put
the roots to it and everything man
after i took like my my r and r i was a
dude was bored dude yeah i feel you i i
hear that i hear that and you know once
we get back into the swing of things i'm
sure when another break comes up yeah
i'll get like that too but um no i saw
you guys um i'll pee yeah um every
sunday now at uh 1 pm eastern standard
time since everybody else is up time
oh man
here we go since everybody else's uh
football teams are out of playoff
contention shout out to washington um
everybody else's teams are out of
contention so this back at 1 pm you guys
had uh mr boomstick on in acg right
alrighty alrighty hey so if you guys
haven't seen that
oh wait oh indeed indeed especially with
those two gentlemen especially what
y'all for man so it is what it is man
after this podcast of course you guys go
back check it out um hey before we get
started um what games you've been
playing over the break
um
let me think i played a lot of halo
actually like
an excessive amount of halo but one
thing i can say is like
when it comes to
like
the break i played a lot of bravery
default i've been playing
an excessive amount of oculus here
lately uh for those of you that don't
know i did just have a review go up on
the iop channel today so definitely go
check that out uh to me this is iop
light i i i respect that man i respect
that iop like i'll take that
yeah because like we do keep a lot of
the same rules of iop because like i
don't really cuss on there either
uh but i enjoy more of the the the dual
aspect because i love iop but when you
have four strong personalities on a
podcast sometimes i can't get my bars
across you know
and that i have an adhd matter so that's
why i interrupt a lot on iop and i'm
trying to get better at it because like
i like my mind just wants to talk 24 7
if there's something i want to talk
about so i'm trying to get better on
that because i know that's a huge
feedback from people and i've been
working on it i got the little the
little raised hand thing man i got that
going on i'm trying man uh that's why
like you know um that's why i like these
too because uh you know it's just me and
hustle we are gonna have throughout this
year we're gonna have a lot more
high-profile guests
uh you know clearly
i've met people because of iop and you
know a lot of them are very interested
coming on here and uh chatting it up
with me and hustle uh so you know we
gotta i got a few people lined up you
know people like uh jeff grubb you know
he said he's come on here uh acg's gonna
come on here eventually uh
won't be in february i can tell you that
right now i i feel bad for that man in
february
i was about to say he got a whole lot of
work ahead of him man he he got it
he got it man um
horizon zero dawn two oh wait i know i
know this isn't a topic but just quick
thoughts on the alleged
leak
leak of a horizon zero
so apparently they remember what
happened with the last of us two however
leaked early had like a bill leaked
early and somebody had put it out they
did the same thing some yeah i'm not
saying the same exact thing happened but
there is an early build of that complete
version of that game out so y'all be
careful on um twitter and all the other
social medias i saw it on gamespot this
morning like the as you sent me the
topics i want to tell you like 10
minutes later that's when that that's
when the alert came up on my phone
through a game spot the little game spot
app so y'all be careful man i'm i'm kind
of looking forward to it i'm actually
going to play the first one starting
monday so we're going to see what it's
hitting for but
man i don't know just be careful if you
are a fan of that game just be careful
yeah so you know look we could tackle a
couple of the little stuff real quick
that's not on the agenda just
just a couple topics so you know we are
talking about halo infinite in the cross
play thing because there's a lot of
cheating going on and i've seen
petitions begging for the cross play to
be eight but you know let's talk about
halo real quick besides the cross play
okay i will say these cosmetics are
getting a little out of hand a little
bit a little bit out of hand how do you
feel about that
wait is that a good out of hand or a bad
out of hand because like
i'm gonna keep it real with you man they
need a little stupid cat ears they need
all that no no
i don't what would you mean what's that
i don't mean like i feel like some of
them are just crazy priced
oh oh my oh my god yeah yeah yeah yeah
don't don't pay for none of that i
understand they gotta make their money
and stuff but what something on there
was like super basic and i think it was
like 20 dollars
i i'm good look look just i just play
the game to have fun i bought um one
skin though i bought the uh
it's the sentinel skin i think the the
team sentinel scan like i always use
that one so like i don't have like a
need for the other ones but
is it let me ask you something because i
know you i mean excuse me pardon me um i
know you've been playing that a lot more
than me i've been getting it every so
often is it easier with the are the
challenges easier because i thought they
said they're gonna make adjustments to
that are they offering the same
cosmetics
um
i haven't been playing it to that degree
but what i will say from what i've seen
is it seems like they're getting better
on that now it looks like
the reason we see what we're seeing now
is because it does look like they're
going towards more of a destiny approach
that's different
like in destiny they have this place
called eververse and you could buy stuff
with bright dust or you could buy stuff
with silver uh the only difference
between destiny and halo right now is
there's no bright dust option there's no
option where you can take an in-game
currency that you earn throughout the
months and you could buy something that
you want in in that shop because it has
two different shops like obviously the
bright dust shop maybe 10 15 things but
the silver shop is pages long you know
what i'm saying but the bright dust
stuff eventually
as long as you have the bright dust the
bright dust isn't something that's
mad easy to get but if you play the game
you're gonna get bright dust you can get
pretty much anything you want in that
store as long as within reason like you
don't go out and spend all the bright
dust you have on dumb stuff but you know
you can eventually get the stuff that
you need and the stuff that you want now
when i'm seeing halo infinite i think
they need something similar where they
need a store that's with in-game
currency
and you get that currency way
way slower than anything else maybe you
do uh the the weekly challenges and you
get a currency and then what would
happen is
they'll rotate pretty much last season's
stuff
onto that bright
uh store that bright dust store so for
instance
let's say that they updated
you know three months ago that was the
last update for destiny now you would
start laos since it's a new update and
you and they put new stuff in the
cosmetic store you'll start seeing a lot
of that old stuff that you wanted three
months ago in that bright dust store uh
so that's how they do their stuff where
it's not necessarily you could buy the
new stuff from the most part there are
certain exceptions in destiny but for
the most part if you want something that
is that's hot now that's in that that
store now you have to buy it now but if
you don't want to buy now you could wait
a little bit for instance you know who
you know they have like a weekly thing
where if you do all the weekly
challenges they give you something for
free
i would not be surprised in three or
four months the bunny years is there you
know what i'm saying where if you do all
the weekly challenges you'll get that
weekly reward and it will be the bunny
years but i think it needs to be more
than just one
cosmetic they need
maybe you do like you do it once and
they give you the option of three or
something you know what i'm saying or
you could just pick one of them because
i do feel like right now
i will say it's we are starting to look
different than other spartans you know
what i'm saying like for the most part a
lot of spartans look
different like cognito got this like
like
ronin shown thing going on with the the
the uh what's the rose pedal stuff and
so like really
he's looking like a power ranger to some
point with the red so you know we are
having
spartans look different
but you know
you got to pay that different money so
i understand their concept
but i do feel like there needs to be a
better middle ground and i do think that
they're going to work on that and i
think that that weekly challenge reward
thing is how they're going to do it and
i think the only reason we're not seeing
that is because we're only seeing what's
here now we're not seeing what that
weekly system is going to do throughout
the next couple months like there's a
weekly
item every week so if you keep getting
that weekly item for the next couple
months that's going to be a lot more
stuff throughout the next couple months
that you're going to have as long as you
stay active in the game and i think the
issue is just there's not enough options
with that weekly stuff
all right all right
all right can we get into like the meat
potatoes at least this first one the
halo infinite
you know x boy or xbox fanboys they
crying about crossplay can we please get
into that please yeah we can talk about
that now thank thank you sir listen
listen first and foremost
all right
if people are cheating on pc all right
just put the little pc cheat thing in
there like they do with gears 5.
problem mostly solved right mostly soft
i say
stop crying so much we want the option
to take it off shut up shut up
play the game with the pc with your pc
brethren microsoft wanted y'all to play
the game with the pc people the whole
time anyway now you got it and y'all yo
hey i don't know how long you've been
around but i remember when xbox first
got like the pc thing it's like oh we
want to play with pc we want to play
with pc and a lot of people was like you
know a few peop pc people was like nah
nah nah right and then when they finally
got what they're asking for now they
want to they want to renege on it they
want to go back i'm not rolling man i'm
not rolling all those bums on on console
get good
that's it
i'm i'm sorry i'm sorry look i play on
pc
this is how i get down look i'm like a
silver full before y'all you know before
y'all kill me in the comments i'm still
before i'm just talking [ __ ] however
however stop complaining so much
my my question my first question to you
is have you experienced any type of
cheating with the pc dudes online
that's my first day okay people yes i
have a completely different objective
than a hustle is get some pc cheaters up
out of there like
let's get them up out of there because
i'm not going to see an act like they
ain't no cheating going on every time we
let the pc people in the realm of fun
they mess it up
and i've gotten to the point where i'm
about
gatekeeping with pc gaming okay i don't
want that pc
multiplayer nonsense in my games because
every time we let them in the reindeer
games they'd be cheating
look i get i get what you're saying
that you know there are some that are
really good that are being portrayed to
be cheating the the the problem is
that's very far in between when i get
sniped when i when i'm jumping up in the
middle and i get no scope snipe from
halfway across the map i got an issue
with that when i like when i get shot
through walls i got an issue with that
when someone get when someone literally
kills three like what six cl six bullets
in a in a sniper clip and they get six
kills i got an issue with that no one is
that good in that in any game
do you go go look at pro circuits they
they miss all the time
hey i could contest that i'm not going
to um first of all i don't think it's a
pc thing the reason why you guys are
seeing so many cheaters the reason why
you guys are seeing so many cheaters and
playstation they're going to deal with
this too is because the game is free to
play um halo infinite as we all know is
free to play came out november 15th
after the whole like surprise revealed
and everything that's the reason why
i've seen so many cheetahs um
yes sir yes
so um
we do have uh examples of the cheating
actually being proven warzone uh did
they not disable cross play for uh sea
of thieves hustle
wait did they i don't play things you
guys you had to educate me you got to
educate me okay
people were uh people were shooting from
halfway across the sea and see thieves
and so wait wait hold on hold on hold on
hold on my fault you said sea of thieves
see sea of thieves yes
um
there's mad cheating in um
involved what's that game um
what's that game what is that game fall
fall fall out fall
fall
what's that game
fall guys fall fall guys doesn't matter
and we can agree i know you've seen that
yeah oh yeah yeah we said we definitely
saw people fly across the map they fixed
it though
but if people are willing to cheat and
fall guys what makes you think halo off
limits
i'm not it's only because it's free to
play um and also i read but i don't i
can't agree with that because people are
cheating on free to play games all the
time
well okay okay well let me finish
they're not doing permabans either
though um microsoft from what i've read
and tim
did i forget what the article was but
he's a reputable source he's on twitter
all the time his name is tim and i
definitely forgot but i read that
article this morning um he was like
they're not doing permabans which is
kind of odd to me but if mike microsoft
got to implement that too like they
definitely gotta like
like put their foot down in that regard
so anti-cheat that we see we need uh
we need perma bands we're like we need
server
no ipads and we need ipvans like they're
not doing that they're banning people
yeah but they just banned like the
account so you know with a free-to-play
game it's like a youtube soccer count
that ain't nothing just uh
you know for me to make another one and
i'll be right back at it
i agree tell me
well you know how to go
because here's the thing like the reason
i'm zero
z tolerance thing when it comes to maybe
you've been in the in the cheating pool
so long hustle if you just see it all as
one thing because when i was playing
destiny
it was real
it was real real and not only was people
cheating they were exploiting
and
like look i'm not saying that every
sniper that shoots a headshot
is is is cheating all i'm saying is
there's enough of it going on that when
i do get headshot
i'm pulling out that magnifying glass
and you call me sherlock sherlock addict
because i'm sitting here looking at the
screen that's like is that genuine did
he really get that sniper or was there
an aimbot helping him shoot my dome
the attic attic uh and you know i just
want to let you and everybody else know
that y'all know hello infinite like
heavy on the aim assist i don't even use
mouse and keyboard on i'm on pc by the
way i don't even use mountain keeper
wouldn't i still be at that joint
halfway beast and like
the aim assist is like super heavy but
i would love to see because i haven't
like in all seriousness and you know
we'll be just joking around and stuff
but i have not experienced like a quote
cheater yet like i haven't seen it i
haven't even seen like footage online
about it i know that people were making
like reddit posts and things of that
nature but i did like maybe i wasn't
looking hard enough even but like every
time i play we play objective and you
know either we win or we lose but it's
never like a last lot i think yes sir
yes buddy don't make me go on youtube
and search
halo infinite cheating confirmed we will
do that
we'll have a show and tell and show
everybody people's dirty laundry for the
record
uh uh uh oh like i'm not cool with the
cheating all jokes aside but they need
to start doing perma bands i i haven't i
haven't looked i haven't looked for
either the thing is about permanent
bands i don't think that's gonna do
nothing because it is free to play
people
even if you ip band people that are
cheating there's a lot of them are going
to know how to get around that there's
ways to get around ippens
um
i think does it
yes i think 343 is going to have to do
343 and microsoft's gonna have to do a
bungie and destiny did which is
go after the people
that are distributing the cheats like
you're gonna have to pull up with some
decisions you got to pull up some
lawsuits you're gonna have to make it
clear if the entire industry came
together and they're like if you sell
cheats to my game you going down
and if everyone did that i'm confident
the cheating will drastically down
because the problem is when you could go
and buy a 45
aimbot does this you
oh yeah for sure um
uh shout out to black man over there
weapon wheel like people do need to be
held like legally like responsible at
that point because they are costing halo
money like we being real um i had a
question though um i read and that the
article that i read was from the verge
and that was tom warren who wrote that
article um he stated in that article
that xbox kind of
they don't really give you a choice to
cross to turn off cross play between
like the pc gamers and the xbox gamers
and at first with battlefield 2042
playstation had that option to cut it
off and then like an outpouring came out
from the xbox counterpart from those
packs fans like they implemented the end
so i wonder what's going on behind the
scenes to where they are they're forcing
that because like that's that's a little
odd to me i understand that they wanted
to do it in industry standards at this
point where it's like we're gonna force
everyone to play i don't mind playing
with the playstation peasants
i don't know but that's right
i don't even mind playing with the
switch
people oh myself yeah all right i do
mind playing with the pc people um
from a variety of different things
i think that you know
pve content is fine if we do destiny
raids
destiny strikes
let the cheaters in there because
they're gonna be cheating for my benefit
but
and you know i think where do you think
phil if you're in a partied squad
if you're in a partied squad
let me handle this real quick because
i keep getting
all right so it's that one let's check
this out i keep getting
a bunch of like notifications and i had
to click it real quick to find out who
is getting hit me with stuff over and
over again so how do you feel
let's say that you because they can't
prove
what
they can prove
what type of
people are with you so like if you're in
a partied group
how do you feel about them
banning the whole group if you're in a
party group and they know you're
cheating if me you erica
and mark are playing a game and i'm
cheating away
and you guys know i'm cheating because
you're in a partied group with me
and they catch me and they ban all of
you too
how do you feel about that
i mean i'm about to take a drive down to
you know where you stay at that point
because that's that's why but no but it
should be that way if i know that if if
i know that you cheating then i off on
my head as well though like it ain't
ain't no way around there so i guess
what it should do is i should get the
perma band and the other people should
get a temp band
yeah obviously you raised a good point
if you're playing with other people that
are cheating you should never get
permanent ban you should always get like
a two-day ban
but
it should be one of those things where
it's like we're gonna punish you but we
know
at the end of the day you can't you
can't control what that man is doing
but i do think there should be a point
where they are getting some form of
repercussions
yeah i'm one thousand percent but i'll
be real with you if microsoft and i said
i called it the quote-unquote black bond
approach if microsoft does decide to
take like legal action
i mean
cheaters could run rapid they they're
gonna have to make a big example out of
somebody and somebody will have to go
down for that because like they're
losing three four three at that point
and microsoft will be losing xbox we'll
be losing a lot of money like i like i
said i'm not saying that people aren't
cheating of course they are and it's
been confirmed in that article by the
verge too shout out to tom moore but uh
i'll just say this
if i'm playing having a good time and i
run across you know a map like i think
it was in pub g
i play pubg at first people was running
around with no heads in pub g so you
couldn't get a head shot well like a
sniper rifle and all that attic i'm not
sure if you remember that but
that game was like super hot and like
they waited so long to fix the issue
that it you know it ended up falling off
now fortnite came in and you know did
what it did but the game ended up
falling off for a myriad of reasons and
that was one of them
cheetahs running rampant was one of them
man um
it was kind of like that in gears 5 2
from what i remember i got i have over
130 hours in that and it was just you
could tell like when people was eating
shots and i had to cheat too but like
you can just you could tell sometimes
like certain things that were happening
shouldn't have should not have been
happening when i was running the
multiplayer but they
they gonna have to fix that um
yo this game's been on what two months
right three months at the most
yeah about three months about three
months
i i love i love i love the multiplayer
like it's fine it's super fun um it
reminds me of halo 3 but they gotta
hurry up and fix that because you know i
feel like it's gonna be well we know
it's gonna be like a long haul type of
thing but it's gonna have like ebbs and
flows and i don't want this game to turn
into what halo 5 turned into
to be honest with you what's up i can
never see it being truly fixed it's
always going to be an issue but my thing
is like
i feel like the industry itself needs to
do a better job i i know for a fact from
people i've talked to that
oh the reason a lot of game multiplayer
games gets delayed on pc so long is
because like
a lot of a lot of people in the industry
feel like working
in the pc
community and not necessarily like the
players but you know steam epic store
uh you know
working uh developing a game with pc
because they don't have to worry about a
closed ecosystem they have to worry
about uh you know a variety of different
mechanical parts like a lot of
developers and publishers find it as a
headache they do it because it's
profitable but that's why you see a lot
of games delayed because they don't see
that pc port
is
okay we're not going to delay the game
because at the end of the day we know
the bulk of ourselves are probably going
to come for the consoles so they'll
delay the pc port uh
that will work whenever it works so
whenever we get that work and sometimes
companies like ubisoft and square enix
they're like you guys are just gonna get
what we give you
like we don't even care
if it runs if we can get you past the
title screen i feel like we we succeeded
so you know and
i feel like
if the industry would take the pc
cheating
in terms of multiplayer more seriously
i can't imagine what it's like to be a
primary pc gamer because i tried it once
and i did not have a good time
uh a huge destiny fan
and the cheating on that is ridiculous
also like it's on another level
like you play trials of osiris you're
being cheated on point blank there's no
way around it it's being cheated on and
i think that's the biggest issue i got
with old matter is like i feel like that
particular part needs to be fixed
but uh you know anything how how would
you handle it do you think there's a way
to fix it
i don't know um and thank god because
i'm not a dev like well i guess the
first thing that i said was install
anti-cheat just to see
if you can cut most of that out
i don't really know how to go further
beyond that
outside of like hey look you got to
start you know ip banner a lot of them
now you say that there's there are ways
around you know around the ipad right
that's when you gotta
you gotta get the your lawyers on the
phone you know microsoft lawyers they
they strong as linebackers boy i tell
you they look they just
they got to run down on them at that
point because at that point you got to
make an example out of somebody like
whether it's a hefty fine jail time
whatever it is because
like you you're literally taking money
out of a lot of people pocket over there
at 343 and xbox so i mean i i would you
know
had a team run down on them you know hit
him with so many you know litigations
make him uncomfortable we see nintendo
do it all the time by the way
what's funny is
no one messes with nintendo
i mean that's right they just they get
leaned but my point is is is you don't
see the type of stuff going on in pc
that you see with nintendo because for
the most part there might be the
the little sprinkles of dumb people that
will try to mess with nintendo but the
smart people the majority of people in
the back are like let the pawns try to
go after nintendo because we know
they will bankrupt us they don't care
and i feel like the industry needs to be
that way with cheating where it's like
people are like we're not gonna we're
gonna try to make money somewhere else
because if we try to make it to making
cheating software
everyone will come after us and it'll be
bank the reason people do this because
it makes financial sense but the reason
but the after you take that financial
sense out of the equation everyone's
going to stop making anti-cheats i mean
cheat software sure there will be
stragglers that do it but the the
problem is to take 80 percent of the
cheating out of the field i can deal
with the 20.
yeah i mean i i feel like and attic you
say you can deal with the 20 until you
ain't counting that 20 man but now
that's that's not cool man don't cheat
in the games if you're a bum just knows
come on over here with me man
we got enough room over here it's cool
it's cool just just have fun playing the
game man that's it it's
just sitting that soul man um hey addict
real quick before we transition on to
the next topic do you see uh is is halo
infinite in esports my first question
yes
do you see this being put on
abc nbc or abc espn like overwatch was
probably it just depends on how well the
pro circuit
uh is structured actually i got some
friends in that scene i might see if one
or two of them will come on i've always
wondered how like the pro markets like
funded how the pro market is uh done
because i don't know nothing about that
but well i mean if there's anything to
go by i mean you know robert craft the
owner of the new england patriots
apparently he is an esport team so
so if you're wondering how i think
certain things are getting funded a lot
of
a lot of the billionaires are putting
money into the esports scene which real
quick by the way um shout out to arena
on g4 it's my first
bit of like esports that's like the
first thing that i saw four week four
days playing counter-strike going on
that i wanted to take time to mention
that because that was like my origins of
watching like people compete on a video
game for the very first time
and i think people need to realize too
that you know
what gaming has finally gotten to espn
in general like
i i don't do the sports stuff but i know
for a fact while talking to friends that
are in that scene that
people didn't respect it like at all
like especially like the sports people
they're like it's not a contact sport
we're not going to cover it but then
like but then you see people covering
like is it chess in like the olympics or
something like that
yes chess is the olympic sport yes yes
so
i i don't i don't have no respect for
that kind of opinion because at the same
time look it might not be a contact
sport but a chest can get up in there i
can get up in there you know
i mean
you know not me because i i'm not i'm
not all that but you know
let's get into
we already destroyed one of the topics
man i didn't even expect to talk about
it that fast but we're going to talk
about something that's kind of important
to me also i don't know if you saw this
but it was reported and
rumored
that it's a possibility xbox
doesn't get any
final fantasy game
going forward
well
this generation they didn't really say
keep in mind first off chat
none of this is approved none of this is
locked in stone but
it is highly rumored and i
and i and i trust these i do
that
we're not going to get like huge final
fantasy games going forward like people
are like oh attic what about the
paradise game what about it that's not a
final fantasy game that's a spin-off
like man i hate when people take the one
thing and act like it applies to
everything get over yourself
so look look only on xbox who cares who
cares keep final fantasy
all right hustle let me talk to only on
xbox okay
all right
only on xbox hear me out only hear me
out
this is the reason final fantasy is
important
because i say it's important
it's my franchise
okay i'm on xbox i want my final fantasy
i will go on top of the tallest
mountains and screen this until it
happens at the end of the day
it's important man let let's be serious
here let's be let's let's be serious
only on xbox the reason that it's
important is because
they've never really had a huge
grasp on the jrpg market
and
the re one part of the reason for that
is because when you don't get the like
the top tier
jrpgs and you're only getting like the
middle tier the lower tier
what how do you expect to like gravitate
towards like a huge audience in that
area for instance like i'm not a sports
person
but imagine
if
playstation only got like madden like
only got the sports games and imagine if
xbox gets like the mid-tier sports games
and like like the what's that baseball
game that people kept saying xbox had
for the longest time not not uh
not the show but it was like some indie
sports game
so or something like that like imagine
you don't get the maddens the the 2ks
imagine if you got live instead of 2k
and
throughout the years
do you see people playing like on the
actual xbox brand do you see people
actually investing time into
a lot of those
genres when they're not getting the best
ones
like we don't get final fantasy we don't
get persona
uh up until recently we didn't get
dragon quest which we got the last one
but it's debatable if we keep getting
that
you know up until recently we'd get
yakuza uh we got like a dragon and i see
i'm willing to come out of my thing and
say microsoft is working on it
but i personally feel hustle and you
know tell me if i'm wrong tell me my
bugging hustle tell me if i'm [ __ ] i
personally feel like if microsoft can't
get their hands on final fantasy
they need to do something to make that
up to their audience they need to do
something to establish
that type of genre on something like
game pass because keep in mind at the
end of the day this is for game pass you
want diversity in game pass and there's
a lot of people that play jail rpgs
guess where they're playing at right now
hustle
they're on playstation
guess where they're trying to get people
off of hustle
playstation so it's just like that
that's my point it's like look like if
microsoft can't get their hands on final
fantasy
they need to be doing everything they
can to bring
to bring final fantasy light games to
the platform and at this point because
sony's done such a good job at you know
keeping final fantasy they might need to
pull out the paycheck and get some
exclusive games on their platform that's
right past day and date
you said might need to know they that's
that's what they they're going well
better though i'm gonna watch my
language that's that's what they better
do square is like
uh you know their third party developer
like
i i looked up like once when you sent me
this topic i say well let's see how many
final fantasy games you know came on
xbox
i see 13 i see 15.
i see 10 i see 10 2
which hey i think i should play that one
um i see a ton of different games on
this i'm like well let's say they've had
a relationship with them before i wonder
how much they sold i guess that's my
first question my second uh comment i
guess is
um
for spoken
now for those of you who don't know
it's not a ps5 exclusive because it is
on pc but xbox gamers probably won't see
that game at all
but by the look of things i looked up
for some research just to see if it was
like a time thing and i'm addict you
remember a little while ago i forget
what episode it was but a little while
ago
i said i said damn
why we ain't seen final fantasy remake
on xbox yet and you kind of you had an
answer but not really because none of us
really knew
yo squares i literally told you it
wasn't coming
hey
hey but look i know what i'm told and i
know what went up didn't the um xbox
version go for pre-order or something
like that or maybe i'm thinking about
something else i feel like sometimes
those are
those
i don't know how that stuff goes i don't
know how you mess up to that degree
i do know even if that is the case there
is a good
very solid possibility that
that at the end of the day was changed
at the last minute because we know games
like the outer worlds not the outer
worlds uh
right what is that game that
everyone played came to game pass last
year um writers what is it um all riders
cha help me out man it came to game pass
it's published by square enix it's the
destiny clone
outros yeah okay outriders all right so
we saw games like that get put in game
pass at like the last minute so like
deals can be made
very close now keep in mind
that tomb raider the tomb raider um the
rise of the tomb raider
that was originally supposed to be a
multiplayer and then remember microsoft
came in between
that gamescom in the next e3 it said
this is mine like
so i mean stuff can always be done and
you know i feel like
to me
i don't think this is microsoft's fault
i think
at the end of the day
there is a relationship between
sony
and square enix that microsoft will
never have
yeah um i'ma agree with you one thousand
percent on that and you know here's the
thing
even though square is back cool with
nintendo
i just for a second just i want to take
you all the way back remember 20 25 30
years ago whatever final fantasy 7
should have been on the nintendo 64 but
nintendo in their arcade ways came up
with cartridges on the n64 as opposed to
cds just because like the fast faster
memory time so on and so forth we know
how the rest of that story went
and playstation pretty much went on to
be dominant because of like listen
if you had a playstation one
it seemed like everybody i knew had
final fantasy and they weren't even into
rpgs like that i think they just saw
like the little stuff in the magazine
but it was i knew like seven eight
people wouldn't enjoy let's just say
five of them had it let's just say more
than half of them had it man so
that's that's like a tie that that won't
um stop um that that relationship is
like super strong um
now microsoft won't get there unless
they offer an obscene amount of money
and the reason why they do that like hey
let's be real addict you know the xbox
audience they're not really
into that they're not really into it i
understand you you got to be diverse but
they're not into that yeah but that's
why i brought it up you can't
expect an audience to be into a certain
type of game
well we don't get that game
uh for instance kingdom hearts 3 it sold
okay but it didn't so amazing on the
xbox well how did they expect it to so
amazing when the first two was it on the
platform
hold on let me let me respond to uh mr
clay mud in the chat you got a good name
by the way
hey man you say yo you say you need
japan in that squad i mean well
obviously right but here's the thing
if square went up for sale today
i bet you microsoft would offer an
obscene amount of money to get them like
you you like i would say like bethesda
level because square square plus had a
lot of good content that's there's a lot
with that back catalog and i don't want
to talk about the acquisition stuff but
that there's a whole lot to to get with
with square in particular and and that's
but that's that's a big deal and you
know attic speaking of acquisitions i
know we were talking about that on one
of the episodes before about different
acquisitions like a starting five and
who would you take and just that in the
third
it looks like square is just gearing up
to partner up with sony that's what it
looked like that's what it looked like
to me with the whole
final the final fantasy 7 thing kind of
like really like just started that for
me
but it looked like they just they about
to go home man they bout to go right on
home and yeah i mean
snuggle up next to sony man that's
that's what's about to happen snuggling
up next to the playstation man jim ryan
about to be eating good over there
they're going to square
i give it i'll be honest with you
i give it about three years if well
spoken doesn't do well and something may
change behind the scenes
i i think i think they acquire square
because you know microsoft they they're
gonna want to buy a spree like they just
get they get the the platinum card and
you just go right
i think i think we're gearing up to see
that and i think that's gonna be a
monumental like shift in like
playstations too uh playstation sales
rather
yeah come on
i agree because
i don't know like what's interesting if
you look at the trends that's going on
right now you'll see that
they're kind of pawning off the western
part of their of their company they
pawned off the crystal dynamic they you
know they're doing a lot more in terms
of focusing on the eastern stuff they
have going on for them so like it's kind
of interesting how they're doing that
now i don't see
square being bought by sony
anytime soon
because i do feel like the final fantasy
franchise is going to do enough to keep
them afloat for going on out
but you know who knows maybe leadership
will change i just don't know if sony
will be willing to put the kind of check
out that would be required to buy square
enix now i i'm not one of those people
that says they don't have the money they
do have that money but i don't know if
they're willing to spend that kind of
money it's to to purchase that
to that company because keep in mind
it's easier for microsoft to go to their
investors and say we need 7.5 billion
dollars to buy bethesda when they have
that in cash you know what i'm saying
it's not a it's a lot harder to go to
because let's say 7.5 billion dollars if
that flops it's going to hurt but it's
not the end of the world for but uh for
microsoft you know what i'm saying yeah
that's crazy to hear you say that too by
the way yes jesus
if
sony made that type of investment it
didn't pan out that would hurt them
so
it's not that they couldn't do it and
they can't
and i would say that every company that
could convince their investors to invest
into something like that it would be
sony but it's just it's it's up in the
air if that would ever happen
um
i mean look it's the whole
xbox final fantasy and this is a room
and it's a speculation on our part this
is kind of why we're all over the place
with it i don't think um you guys get a
final fantasy i think the best place to
play that will be on playstation i think
the best place to play that will be on
pc
but it won't be on xbox because it won't
be there it won't be on the switch
because it won't be there sorry
squares
it just seemed like squares
they loyal like they just they said now
we want to we want to sell any money we
don't want nothing we want the sony in
this pc money we don't want nothing else
that's that's how i seen
um when i when i first saw it like all
of that was going on i was like
like i said i wanted to look just to see
what different games they came over
if
if microsoft ever does get like the
final fantasy 7 remakes it'll probably
be on the xbox what's this thing
xbox series wow whatever it'll be on the
next gen
next generation what's up
let me because i see only on xbox people
are saying we only we need bethesda we
don't need you know the japanese
role-playing games like i agree with you
but that is a huge advantage and they
have a huge pulse when it comes to
the western market there's no denying
that
but let me ask you guys a question
wouldn't it be nice to be the place to
go to play rpgs in general doesn't
matter what type of rpg it is
uh and you don't even need to to make
sure you don't even need to lock down
exclusives on the japanese market just
gotta make sure they come to your
platform
like
if you have all the western market
exclusive to your platform besides a
couple studios that make very good games
but it's just not you know they got
obsidian but there's the software
studios they got the people who are
making fable
they got uh obsidian's making two games
they got a lot of
uh they got um the people make wasteland
exile entertainment they got a lot of
people making those type of games but my
question to you is if you're able to
make sure that more games like final
fantasy come to the platform because i
think final fantasy is out of the out of
the question now but if you make more
games like final fantasy come to the
platform and you're also getting those
western rpgs your box is the only place
to play rpgs at that point you can't do
that on mike on sony because you've
already locked up half of the after you
have to the companies that make those
type of games it do does microsoft own
every rpg company of course not but at
the same time
you're going to want to be as diverse as
possible and there's a completely
different section of
section rpgs than just western rpgs
you know if you want if you want
microsoft to do better worldwide not
just in the states people always say
addict only matters when it's it's in
the in america to a point i agreed to
because we live in this this country so
a lot of the stuff that happens when
most of us live in this country i don't
i know a lot of our fans come from
america but i know there are some around
the world but i'm speaking for the the
states right now all right so i can
understand you have that mentality that
you only care about sales and stuff
that's coming from our states but at the
same time microsoft's never going to
have a worldwide appeal unless they try
to appeal to a worldwide audience and
right now they're doing it but they're
not doing it enough they need to make
sure that they get these final fantasies
on the platform they get these personas
on the platform look at game pass game
pass is doing fantastic you know what
better game pass with jrpgs in it
sure they have done good to get final
fantasy games but at the end of the day
they got final fantasy games that was
damn near 10 15 years old you think
they're going to do a whole lot imagine
persona 6 comes to game pass day and
date
oh oh that's that'll be legendary um let
me answer uh splendiferous
question to me
would i leave it would i leave a
multi-player i i treated like minecraft
and leaving multiplayer that's that's
just but that's just me that's just me
personally you you actually brought up a
good point
and with everything that you were just
saying like yo the way that you have to
appeal to the eastern audience is to
pretty much have eastern type games over
there fan fantasy is the biggest one
it's pretty much the biggest well one of
the biggest ones over there that dragon
quest uh you know a lot of people were
going crazy off a potential um
chrono trigger remake which
we didn't see or was it chrono trigger
chrono cross it was one of one of them
chrono games that a lot of people were
speculating that we would have were to
have seen at the game awards but it
didn't happen
but having that having those types of
games over there like yeah i get it i
get it but if you're asking me i'll
leave that joint third party man but
play that joint whatever man watch that
joint do numbers still
see the the problem is it's not third
party you know there is a lot of games
that's being
that's just naturally being exclusive to
the playstation platform uh you know i
don't know what's going on there you
know we could throw out assumptions all
day but i'm trying to stay away from the
assumptions
we simply don't know why stuff's not
coming to xbox i don't know if it's not
that they're not willing to sell it on
the platform or you know there's a lot
of speculation going on there but ever
since game pass came to tuition that a
lot of developers are holding their
stuff off of the xbox platform
intentionally because they want that
game pass bag down the road i don't know
if that's true
uh but you know i would say that that is
something that would make sense
logically but business-wise i don't know
i don't know about that but
no attic wants all of jrpgs on game pass
clay mud that's not the case i just want
microsoft to do better in that genre
because i want microsoft to succeed for
instance
they are not the place to play fighters
i don't play fighters i don't care about
fighters but i know there's a lot of
people that do care about fighters
they they own one of the
that one of the most profitable not
profitable i don't know how well killer
instinct did but it was one of the most
beloved uh fighters of last generation
and they still haven't done anything
with that brand with that franchise
there is no reason that we're sitting
here with no killer instinct
i got thoughts on that um for those of
you who don't know um well if you if you
follow me on twitter you know i just
brought
capcom versus snk 2. um i'm playing that
for the very first time i played uh
capcom versus snk1 in the arcades back
when i was a wee little lad around 12 13
years old whatever
that to me because maximilian had
actually worked on the first uh killer
instinct if um if i'm getting my facts
right which i got a feeling i am because
i remember him talking about it
i don't know why they haven't come out
with the fighter where their own oh wait
first person he said in the interview
somebody was like hey are you trying to
get street fighter 6 exclusive to xbox
they said no well he said why would i do
that one we got uh we got calendars
things so why would i do that yeah so
yeah and i know we i know we kind of
going off on the tangent cool let's just
talk this little ki talk right quick
they need to do something with this okay
cross it over with something else
you highlight capcom or somebody else
you holla you know holla whoever you
need to go holla at whether it's what
because everybody likes mortal kombat
for some reason i i don't like them but
holler air boom in them and make
something happen there killer instinct
versus motor combat or something like
that a lot of that other stuff could
work like it really could work man at
this point
and i'm just throwing this out there
this is just me throwing this out there
at this point
i think
that if they can't do if they're not
willing to do a killer instinct because
we saw in keller institute they used a
lot of their properties they brought
like arbiter and stuff in there
like reach out you know if anything you
could talk to people that used to work
with these companies that made these
head-to-head fighters that made these
marvel vs capcom games
make you a new studio and have them make
something like like like killer instinct
like
versus something like but like you can
do like that's why i really wanted them
by warner brothers because i felt like
warner brothers
you know i love bethesda i do and i
think bethesda is a very prof a very
company that appeals to me
but me personally i felt like warner
brothers completed microsoft more than
even even bethesda did
i think bedez is a good studio from the
body because they have some quality
games off the bat but i always felt like
warner brothers
was able to give microsoft stuff that
they didn't have uh
if they got netherrealm they could make
a they could have them make a killer
instinct i think probably you would have
a killer instinct versus mortal kombat
first or the more combat versus killer
instinct they probably would name it
that uh and then you know you can have
rock steady make them a comic book hero
game
you can and you know you you have some
other stuff there and you have the lego
franchise that they can keep throwing in
game pass over and over again
i prefer bethesda i actually want to get
technical i prefer them both microsoft
go by warner brothers like but you know
i just feel like if they got warner
brothers i don't think they need to buy
another company personally i think they
they might need to get something in
japan a studio in japan that's why i was
so
pro i was so wanting them to get sega
because if they got sega
they would never have to invest into
another company ever again because they
would have the japanese stuff with uh
sega they would have the western stuff
of bethesda and they would have that
bang bang shoot shoot up stuff with
their core studios
yeah but you know that the dream with
sega in my humble opinion is over
because
i got what i said i bought a
i bought the sonic pardon me i bought
the uh sonic collection right silent
sonic megaplus collection on ogx box
right i bring that up to say this you
can go on steam right now and get all
the sega's older like genesis titles
and the long and short of it is you can
get them all for like 20 bucks or
whatever and i know people
for you know got the the thing about
having to say i get it like i 1000
percent get it but
uh i mean that's just something that you
can you can just let pass because sega
is going to be everywhere anyway so
that's just something that you can let
past uh i want to say i want to take it
back to the versus thing where mortal
kombat and killer instinct
would be a dope a very dope concept um
certain studios or certain or i guess
organizations
they pull off fatalities in in mortal
kombat right
would you really want to see someone
from the killer instinct you know
somebody from over there like get killed
like if you're i don't have like a
vested interest in that company and i'm
i'm saying from just like from the
business perspective not from the frame
perspective i don't i don't really
necessarily
play the killer instinct games i played
it a little bit but there's like a wolf
in there like cyber war for saber wolf i
don't know saber wolf yeah we're going
to go with saber wolf because that
sounds about right um
i'm not saying that their franchise
makes sense
with fatalities
but i think that type of artwork and
stuff they do
you could redirect some of the artwork
maybe put a little bit more gore in it
and it would they could do it if they
wanted to like like injustice i didn't
think that made sense you know what i'm
saying like because i don't see
the
dc universe
ripping like
by uh was ripping superman's brain out
you know what i'm saying
so like that that was my thing when it
comes to something like that but i do
understand
that
you know would be cool if
saber wolf bit off
scorpion's head like you know what i'm
saying like
like but see if you look at the
characters they could totally do that
like
let's see like imagine saber wolf like
jumps up just like a front flip and just
bites straight through scorpion and he
comes up and there's just blood on his
teeth and it says fatality you know what
i'm saying like
not not to mention um they can you know
mortal kombat is famous or infamous for
like the stage fatalities um even like
just going back and just looking at the
old like killer instinct on the arcade
and super nintendo i mean you can always
make something happen from there um
shout out to mooch in the chat um y'all
make sure y'all check out crossfire
every friday night at 7 p.m eastern
standard time man y'all make sure to go
check the mooch out man
check out mooch sometimes we should be a
little extra but he does have an
entertaining
show and and mooch i will say one thing
mooch has like the most
desirable
voice in in this whole youtube thing i
wish i sounded like mooch sometimes man
because that dude has like the best
radio voice you'll ever hear like when
you hear that you feel like you you
would hear that type of voice driving
like down the road on the radio like
hey so basically what you heard i'm
doing asmr man look you got it you got
to mooch him and um you know fonzarelli
has a really good speaking voice as well
i will get fun
we should probably get fawns back on
here eventually
we'll be nice it will be nice
all right so uh let's let's go on to uh
the meat and potatoes i'm sure everyone
here
hold on
yeah i see we'll get to in one second
okay you'll be assaulting xbox we're
going to talk about this but let me get
this super chat real quick
five super chat from mr irishman
if xbox is to get more
japanese support they need to build
their own japanese studios or buy
independent devs like from software arc
system works and level five all right
we're gonna push we're gonna push the
ubisoft thing back a little bit more
hustle
tell me how bad it would be
if microsoft bought from software
hey well as you know as you know addict
i'm not a from software guy that's
that's that's mooch that's uh vendetta
that's erica that's you i i'm good on
that i will promise you i'm good on that
but that would be one hell of an
acquisition and if you didn't have an
xbox before whatever from software is
making after what's this next one what's
what's the game american i'm trying to
get me to play me baron and merc i can't
think of the name of it
uh elden ring elder ring
all right if velden ring hit and i gotta
feel that it is
i mean you can only imagine like like a
fever pitch like at that point if it was
only on xbox man that's
that that'd be crazy to me but you know
but but they put their games everywhere
anyway don't they because it's like i
don't know
what's up is it arc system works uh
don't they do fight head-to-head fighter
games
isn't it no that on people will make
guilty gears and [ __ ] like that i don't
know i don't know anything about
fighters
um
but see
i i feel like they could make that if
they had to
but i don't think it would be the right
thing to do because i don't know
sometimes i have a hard time
like feeling like a studio
could go a different art direction once
they've showed me an art direction if
that makes sense to you like i know they
could do it like logically and
business-wise they could do it but my
mind's like if they're doing these
cartoony works i mean killer anything's
a little cartoony it is
but
yeah i mean maybe maybe i think
you know the the the part of me that
wants them to do stuff that makes sense
would want them to get that for killer
instinct but the messy part i mean the
part that's important wants to pick up
that from software man because
hustle how great of a day that would be
on twitter
i'll just sit back and you know have my
feet kicked up um real quick arc systems
works yes they do make a guilty gear as
well as a myriad of other i love the art
style by the way they make a myriad of
other titles as well that would work for
killer instinct
that type of
game
the guilty gear stuff reminds me of we i
know we going a little long on this it
reminds me of a marvel versus capcom 2.
not exactly but like that hand-drawn art
style it's
but you don't have to draw like i yo
shout out to them because they don't you
gotta draw like different frames of
animation just to make make sure it's
all fluid and everything and that's
that ain't exactly the easiest thing to
do by the way like and i'm no animator
under any circumstances but this is why
we'll probably never see another marvel
versus cap come to
in that art style uh marvel vs uh
uh excuse me capcom vs snk one and two
you'll probably never see another no
other stuff like that because you got to
draw every frame of animation that's
that is insane i'll just say that i was
leaving at that that is
purely that's madness that is madness in
this day and age but
yeah man i i i got you attic but i mean
that that'd be dope if you know they
pick them up but hold on real quick
don't they have to have a
presence in japan before they can buy
japan studio well a studio from japan
rather
tango studios you mean that company okay
cool so i wasn't i wasn't familiar
that's what i was asking so i i i had no
idea studios
i don't know part of me feels like
that's
that's a myth but it's not a myth i feel
like there's
there's like ways around that if people
really truly wanted a company from japan
i might have to really try to find
someone that's in that scene bring them
on the show and tell me whether or not
it's possible for a company like
microsoft to buy a company because i
know
japan will buy stock stocking companies
that's in japan to make sure that
there's no hostile takeovers
but i don't know if they do that with
every company and i don't know
if the companies have to reach out to
japan to do that you know what i'm
saying like or maybe
you know
i don't know i don't know nothing about
that
i'm gonna look into that i'm gonna look
into that see if i can find someone that
you know could come maybe hogue would
know something about that i don't know
maybe we'll know something about that i
might have to get a hold on here man i
have to uh we would just get a bunch of
like myths that's like lawyer-wise just
ask them a bunch of myths
so all right so let's let's
mr irishman definitely uh sidetracked
that whole podcast for about 10 minutes
but that's okay it's a good conversation
let's talk about ubisoft
and xbox
so i'm sure you saw a couple days ago
that uh ubisoft plus is coming to xbox
and they announced in the same tweet
that
rainbow six extraction or extinction or
whatever the hell that game's called is
going to be in game pass day and date so
the biggest question i have to you
hustle
right the only question
is do you think this is the opening
statements that they're going to have
before they actually bring
ubisoft plus
to the xbox platform
are you ubisoft not coming over here or
say here ubisoft is not coming over to
xbox they're not doing it they actually
put out another tweet um because a lot
of people was like tweeting rand and
jazz's information that they was putting
out there as well as a few other bigger
youtubers and everything like that
um
ubisoft came out was like hey we see
what y'all doing but no this that's not
gonna happen ubisoft will remain its own
company as far as the online services
that they have
and um i'll ask you a question
well no i answer a question with a
question who asked for that because a
lot of people didn't even want that game
when it first came out for the record so
i don't want to act excited for that
when i when i saw that when i saw it i
said no i'm good i said am i
i threw my hands up all right cause i
remember that during e3 i said now i'm
good
i said that's that's not for me but no
it's that's not gonna happen and um
i'm interested to to get your thoughts
on it as well but
yeah you know ubisoft came out and shot
that down did you not see that
you ubisoft shot one down ubisoft plus
coming on to game pass
yes
well yeah you'll be so people shoot down
stuff all the time i'm not necessarily
but i get that but we literally have
seen companies that's rumored to have
been bought by microsoft swore up and
down that that's that's false it's not
happening and and six months later they
announced they've been bought by
microsoft like when it comes to stuff
like that it's just pr speak like i'm
not saying that
it's coming and i don't think place i
don't think ubisoft plus is coming to
game pass but all i'm saying is if it
does i can't go off their word you know
what i'm saying like i need
i couldn't go off anyone's word because
people are constantly shooting stuff
down and it happens anyway
so it's it's one of those things where i
would have to just see if it comes out
me personally i feel like what we're
going to see is we're just going to see
more ubisoft games in game day and day
i don't think it's going to be all of
them and i think place i think ubisoft
plus but i do think if ubisoft feels
like a game might misstep when it
launches
that's going on that's going on game
pass
oh i'm looking at i'm on ubisoft's
website right now um yo they want 50 for
this joy
nah
nah buddy it's supposed to come out on
the uh the 20th of this year too um
so about a week week and a half whatever
i'm good
i'm good if i'm playing it
hey you know what's funny i'm on their
website now i don't notice i see a
windows icon and i see hold on i see a
windows icon and i see a playstation
icon but i don't see an xbox one which
is weird
that's weird to me
the only part that's weird to me is how
willingly that they were putting because
we all know how pr is you know these
people sit in a room all day just
thinking about what could go wrong
so it's just like to me why would you
openly
put in the same tweet that we're putting
ubisoft plus onto the xbox platform
which wasn't said it was coming to the
playstation platform let me add and then
in the same tweet say oh yeah and we're
putting uh extraction in a gamepad stain
date like did you see that working well
for you hustle did you see people like
let's be real here do you see a pr
person that is in that profession and
has been doing it for a while
there is no way none of them felt like
you know what people might get the wrong
impression
[Laughter]
well i i'll say that this is the game
that absolutely nobody asked for um
is uh are you watching probably why it's
in game pass yeah yeah i i i'm gonna
keep it i'm gonna keep it true with you
i think they see they saw the reception
of how people kind of took that in
because people are such big siege
players
when that happened they just was like
all right well we'll just cut our losses
here because like i said they wanted 50
dollars for that
man buy from the badass ring for no 50
dollars
if this game succeeds on any any
standard it's because of game pass and
play in ubisoft plus i'm going to try it
because of game pass i was not buying
this game but because it's a game pass
you know i might pull up and you know
set up a chair you know what i'm saying
like i feel like that's pve right
yes pve pb all right well y'all can have
a good time with that y'all let me know
how that go man so
let me just like skip to me yeah yes sir
let's have an alternative universe we'll
call it the added world okay let's have
alternative universe where i have put
in in writing
that ubisoft plus is coming to game pass
how do you think that will work out
first off i want to ask you do you think
that the price for playstation for game
pass would go up in six oh for sure
uh so what i want you to ask that which
you've already answered that but you're
gonna answer it again because we're
gonna do all this together
and do you think that the reception for
game pass will go higher because it's
got ubisoft in game pass ultimate
and we got a two dollar superchat from
flame
even with game pass i'm still not
playing that trash
i appreciate it but i will be playing
that trash attic is in there so it's so
so what do you think hustle
yes no i answered that question before
but it'll probably go up to well what up
what do i pay now it'll probably go up
to 25 it'll probably be like a 10
increase depending on where you go um if
you're on game pass with pc like me you
probably just had to put up 20.
um
the second part of that question would
would it be more desirable yeah would
gameplay be more desirable desirable for
sure listen
i'm not a fan of rainbow six in
particular this is just not my thing for
real uh just it might be a little too
hardcore but i may have to try siege out
just to try just to see if i can get
you know just you know just so i can get
on to it but obviously far cry alone
would be a lot for people um let's see
they make assassins creed i'm just
looking at a few of their games um one
of my favorite games which isn't on here
but um they made they made a version of
tetris which is the one that i said
don't buy but i love tetris so much that
i'll probably just buy it just for that
um tetris ultimate was what they made so
that they have a lot of that that
definitely have a lot of franchises i
mean people like watch dogs just
different different games like that so
it's definitely a viable
option and that's
really that's why ubisoft not going
nowhere because they know they got good
titles those titles would have to sell
abysmal
on all platforms in order for that to
happen in order for the all right come
on let's let's
you know
let's just just you know let microsoft
uh you know take the lead on this for
game pass they would have to they would
have to perform abysmally if that's a
word and if they were i just made it up
what's up
i feel like
game pass ultimate will go from 15 to
20.
i feel like game pass
the standard
for 9.99 would stay 9.99
because i feel like the only reason the
ultimate would go up is because they
they throw ubisoft in there
i feel like
game pass they're going to want that to
be as low as possible for an entry into
game pass
and they're going to want because people
are going to look at 999 and jump in
that because they feel comfortable with
9.99 and they're going to see something
on there with ultimate and then be
willing to pay 10 extra dollars and then
get comfortable with that you know what
i'm saying but
i don't see where they there's a
possibility where they raise 1 to 20 and
1 to 15.
but i mean let's hope that they don't
raise game pass for probably another
year year and a half to two i think i
think we'll get lucky if it's a year
two
i don't two day raising game pass by
then like i don't know we'll see we'll
see how much microsoft's willing to take
that hit you know what i'm saying like
how much they're willing to take that
hit in terms of not raising game pass
just to be
as valued as possible
and this is like my issue when it comes
to this hustle i don't know how you feel
about it is
i just want
to see
more of a diversity in game pass and i
feel like a lot of ubisoft games would
do that it's no secret that ubisoft is
moving away from you know a lot of the
traditional ways of making games and
they're making a lot more games that's
games as a service and uh i don't know
how you feel about this but if they if
they do go through with this and they
make more games as a service like they
claim i feel like they're more open to
putting stuff on game pass because
they're going to make more money in the
long run than just that 50 60 70 they're
gonna lose at the opening front
[Music]
yeah um
if this helps playstation now get their
services in order which i hope it does i
hope iron will sharpen iron in this case
then then i kind of want square to go
over there but i don't think they will
i'm keeping sure with you though i don't
there this isn't a thought in my mind
like those games would have to sell
poorly like extremely poorly
for them not to even make a thing and um
i'll be real with you if they if um
pardon me if ubisoft did go over there
um the one of the games that i'm playing
um one of the one of my most anticipated
games which
it might be vaporware at this point but
it's beyond good and evil too
that's what i'm kind of waiting on from
you
boy that drawing like the detox um man
it's that joining ain't never coming out
it ain't ain't never coming out yes
that's bad you know i don't think
there's a whole lot we could talk about
the ubisoft thing but i do want to talk
about one thing real quick before we
leave
there is a lot of numbers coming out
there that happen today
on saying that microsoft's went over 10
million units
uh
yeah platforms now it's the beta where
playstation is now a lot of people are
trying to say they're like a million
apart that that that that's oh that's
correct i would say if anything they're
like five to six million apart but the
fact that they came from the xbox one
generation
and
they're going over into this and it's
debatable with their five to ten million
units apart like that's not a lot at all
considering how much of a
dominance that sony was having on them
like all the last generation and now you
have a scenario where we're you know a
year
a year and a couple months or a couple
days
past the year uh past the the year point
with these consoles and they're only
five to ten million units apart from
each other and
that's insane because i thought
the way things were last year the last
generation that you would think that the
dom the dominance would be double that
you know what i'm saying like they would
be at 20 25 million and xbox is barely
struggling to get past 10.
i want to dispel
like a part of that
um from the research that i did earlier
today they said they just shipped
around 12 million they didn't say what
they sold
but i just
i know i just i do want to put that out
there first i'm not saying that they
didn't sell because they probably moved
about 10 million we'd been wrong they
probably they probably moved around 10
and you know that whole having a console
for 3 it's the xbox series s which is
the most common one i enjoy 300
that's cool like to me and like
i don't even necessarily need one but if
i wanted to have an xbox if i wanted to
get my foot in the door because i have a
pc but if i wanted to get my foot in the
door it's 300 like and you know there's
a lot of value with gamepad so there's
there's a lot of that going on i
i'm
i want to see more information first
before i really make a
statement on that and i only say that
because
yeah last generation
we we saw you know microsoft pretty much
got curbs down by the competition
like we've been real playstation and
nintendo for that matter playstation
nintendo but
it it's just good to see that microsoft
just has like a fighting chance
you know now they said they moved to a
million that but i saw somewhere they
said they shipped 12 million that sold
12 million
yeah but at this point you know
the way things are going because the way
i was described they're making more x's
than there are s's at this point
um and they're selling x's like crazy
and i i don't see many s's i know there
are products in the world where their s
is on shelves and stuff or people coming
to walmart or some kind of retail like
target
and they literally just stalked and they
take a picture and say look at all these
sitting there because for every picture
i can show you with a bunch of xbox s's
and x's on a shelf i could show you one
with ps5's on a show because it's not
hard for an employee to take a picture
of a shell bef right when they're
stalked
i'm not saying that that's what's going
on but i'm saying that these concerts
are selling the majority of them are
maybe a little bit of the essent on the
shelves for a little bit but talking to
people i know in retail they're all
going all of them they're not sitting
there i mean oculus outsold them both
and part of that reason is because no
one else could buy anything else
but
i digress i'm not gonna argue with that
so
hustle
what are you gonna be doing
later on this week you said
you were coming back to twitch man get
to tell the world tell them what tell
them what you're doing man so they know
where to find you well
i will be playing more than likely what
what's monday monday
next monday more than likely i will be
playing horizon zero dawn because uh the
second one comes out next month but you
can find me at twitch.tv slash hustling
because i'm playing horizon zero dawn on
twitch too
oh man that's that's too perfect um i'm
playing a lot of retro games too um i
don't feel like lifting this up just
know that i have a super nintendo uh
super nt
which
ebitda was there for i do have a
nintendo 64 and i've recently just made
a purchase of a retro tank 5.
real quick what a retro tank 5 does is
that it upscales all of those consoles
which had like 240p 360 resolution
upscales at the 1080p so it can look
nice and you know
hd-ish right or hd like uh it doesn't
improve the graphics or anything but i
don't have to like stretch the picture
out or anything so i will be back on the
retro games um
like i may mention what i brought
earlier with the sonic collection and
the atari collection and uh yeah
i look forward to playing stuff like
this nba jam nba jam tournament edition
i look forward to
really
getting back in my bag
in february for the uh for all of my
like new stuff that i got coming i got
some other shows coming around the
corner too i'm not gonna speak on them
yet because actually addicted as we were
talking my artists had went ahead and dm
me too so i definitely got a lot going
on
i'm not gonna leave in that i'm just
just gonna work through the whole thing
and i definitely understand you know oh
definitely
uh
follow the iron lord's podcast twitch
channel i'm playing horizon zero dawn on
there against my better judgment uh
never played it's coming out next next
month because i do want to review the
next one next month and i feel like i
got to play the first one so definitely
go over there and follow that uh the
iron lords podcast twitch channel i'll
be going live tomorrow at 5 to six pm i
know i'm giving you a duration you're
going to work with me man i gotta i
gotta fit the twitch thing in my life
and it's taking some adjustment but you
gotta work me with that but i appreciate
everyone coming through uh we uh
definitely tune into the iron lords
podcast this 1pm
um
let me look what our guest is i'm not
going to say it obviously but
i'm kind of curious what our guest is
next week
oh okay okay i know who it is but i'm
not allowed to say it so it's gonna be a
good show man uh it's gonna be a new
person so i will say that uh they've
never been on the podcast before uh but
i appreciate it for coming through this
game at it and hustle and motivate
definitely we will catch